the demand for cloud engineering
professionals continues to grow at an
astonishing rate according to the recent
data job postings for cloud related
positions have increased by 146% in the
past 5 years making Cloud engineering
one of the fastest growing career fields
in the United States Salone the average
salary for a cloud engineer is around
$120,000 significant ly higher than the
national average moreover cloud
computing adoption by businesses is on
the rights with Cloud spending expected
to cross $500 billion globally by 2024
all this sounds astonishing but what
does it take to become a cloud engineer
in 2024 what are the skills you will
require to enter this high paying field
today we have got an exciting topic for
you the top 10 skills required for a
cloud engineer in 2024 we'll be breaking
down the essentials that are in high
demand in the ever evolving field of
cloud engineering but before we begin if
you enjoy watching these videos and find
them interesting then subscribe to our
Channel because we bring the best videos
for you da also hit the Bell icon to
never miss any updates from simply also
if you want to become a successful Cloud
expert and gain handsome salary packages
then look at the wide range of cloud
computing courses by simply learn in
collaboration with the top universities
across the globe by enrolling in any of
these certification programs you will
learn to Master the architectural
principles and services of the top Cloud
platforms design and deploy highly
scalable fall tolerant applications and
develop skills to transform yourself
into an AWS or Azure Cloud expert so
what are you waiting for hurry up and
enroll now a year of experience is
preferred to enroll in these courses
find out the link mentioned in the
description box below for more details
so let's start this video with who is a
cloud engineer a cloud engineer is a
tech WI res specializing in designing
building and maintaining Cloud
infrastructure they work with Cloud
platforms like AWS Azure or Google Cloud
to help businesses run their
applications and services efficiently
Cloud Engineers are the backbone of the
digital world ensuring everything runs
smoothly in the cloud moving on to the
salary offered in this role in the
United States alone a cloud engineer's
average salary lies between $100,000 to
$150,000 per year depending upon
experience skills and location in India
a cloud engineer can earn approximately
10 to 20 lakh rupees per year which is
pretty great too now that we know who a
cloud engineer is and how much they earn
let's move on to the skills required to
become a cloud engineer moving on to
skill number one we have Cloud platform
knowledge a deep understanding of cloud
platforms like Amazon web services Azure
or Google cloud is the Cornerstone of
cloud
engineering this includes knowing how to
provision manage and optimize Cloud
resources as well as being aware of the
specific services offered by each
platform Mastery of these platforms
allows you to design and maintain
scalable cost effective Solutions moving
on to skill number two we have Linux
proficiency lenux underpins much of the
cloud infrastructure Proficiency in
Linux especially from the command line
is vital you should be able to manage
users files and directories troubleshoot
issues and perform system administration
tasks this knowledge empowers you to
navigate the server environments that
are common in cloud computing moving on
to skill number three we have networking
effective Cloud Engineers must be well
wored in networking this involves
creating and managing virtual private
clouds understanding IP addressing
routing and security protocols a robust
grasp of networking ensures you can
build secure and high performance Cloud
architectures moving on to the next
skill which is security security is
Paramount in the cloud given the data
sensitivity and applications hosted
there Cloud Engineers must be well vered
in encryption techniques Access Control
identity and access management and the
best practices for securing Cloud
resources this skill is critical to
safeguard against data breaches and
cyber threats moving on to skill number
five containerization Proficiency in
containerization Technologies like
Docker and kubernetes is crucial for
efficient deployment and management of
applications containers in cap software
making it easy to move and scale
applications across different Cloud
environments understanding container
orchestration and management is
essential for modern Cloud engineering
moving on to the next skill devops and
automation devops principles and
automation tools are pivotal in Cloud
engineering devops Foster collaboration
between development and operation teams
enabling continuous integration and
continuous delivery pipelines
proficiency with tools like Jenkins
anible and terraform streamline
infrastructure management accelerates
software development and ensures
consistent deployments moving on to the
seventh skill we have scripting and
coding Proficiency in scripting and
coding languages like python bash or
Powershell empowers Cloud Engineers to
automate tasks create custom Solutions
and develop cloud-based applications
this skill is essential for efficient
Cloud management and adaptability in a
dynamic Cloud landscape moving on to
skill number eight we have database
management handling data effectively is
at the core of cloud engineering
understanding different types of
databases including relational for
example MySQL postr SQL and no SQL for
example mongodb is essential for
managing data storage retrieval and
database performance in the cloud moving
on to skill number nine we have Cloud
cost management keeping Cloud cost under
control is a critical responsibility
Cloud Engineers need to monitor resource
usage Implement cost saving strategies
and optimize resource allocation
effective cost manag management ensures
that an organization maximizes its Cloud
investment while avoiding budget overs
moving on to last skill we have problem
solving problem solving is a Paramount
skill for cloud Engineers because it
equips them to diagnose and resolve many
technical challenges from infrastructure
and security issues to optimization and
scalability it ensures the efficient and
secure operation of cloud environments
enabling them to adapt to evolving
technology Landscapes and provide
practical solutions to keep Services
running smoothly so these are the top 10
skills that can help you become a
successful Cloud engineer in
2024 remember that the path to becoming
a cloud engineer is not fixed and your
journey may vary depending on your
background and career goals so it's
essential to adapt and learn
continuously to stay competitive in the
Ever Changing field of cloud computing
so with that we have come to the end of
this video on top 10 Cloud engineer
skills in 2024 we hope you found this
video informative and helpful you should
now know about the skills required to
become a successful Cloud engineer so if
you're interested in learning more about
different Technologies plenty of
resources are available at simply lo you
can also check out our website for more
information on different certifications
so thank you so much for being here
today we'll see you next time until then
keep learning and stay tuned to Simply
Lear staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here